- Warning. The video you
are about to watch...
- Do not try this at home!
- Or this will happen to you.
You okay Colin?
- Uhhh. Don't eat doughnuts. Ever.
(upbeat pop music)
- Live and direct from Hollywood.
- Another adventure.
We're about to do some
doughnut shop telephone.
- We're gonna try to find
the best doughnuts in L.A.
- What we're gonna do is
go to one doughnut shop...
- And we're going to ask
them what their favorite
doughnut is, and we're gonna
go to the next doughnut shop.
- To the next doughnut shop.
- Until we find the best doughnut...
- In all of Los Angeles.
- Doughnuts are my weakness!
I'm on a lifestyle called
Paleo minus doughnuts.
- It's all about the
Krispy Kreme. Krispy Kreme.
- [Jordan] Ewww! Get out of here!
- [Colin] Yeah, that's disgusting.
- [Jordan] What?
- That's what we eat in Ohio.
No! I shouldn't have said that.
- He's a liar.
- [Steven] What makes a good doughnut?
- Freshness is obviously
the most important
thing with a doughnut.
- Well yeah, you never
want a stale doughnut.
- Fluffiness.
- Sugar-to-dough ratio.
- I compare doughnut shops based on their
chocolate frosted doughnut.
- [Steven] I say we do that!
- This doughnut looks perfect.
- Mine looks like a heart
on the inside actually.
- Awww, yeah! Your doughnut loves you.
- Looks like they use some
authentic chocolate here.
- And I watched her put
the chocolate on the top.
- That's such a good doughnut.
- Yeah, the sugar-to-dough
ratio is appropriate.
- And it doesn't taste gritty!
I hate gritty doughnuts.
- I don't think I've ever
had a doughnut this good.
- That's because you like Krispy Kreme.
- [Colin] You have doughnut
in your hair, Jordan!
- Donut Friend, be my friend.
- Four out of five.
- What? You've had a
better doughnut than this?
- No, but this is the
first doughnut place.
I'm not gonna start out
with five out of five,
and then just assume
there's no better doughnuts.
- I'm into it, but I want to try
the other crazy doughnuts they have.
- Woah!
- This one is called the Srirachosin.
- What is happening?
- It is like a range of emotions.
- But it's actually pleasant.
I mean, it's a meal!
- You know like when you feed
information to a computer,
it shuts down? That's like me right now.
I'm gonna just reboot.
- Internal error. Internal error.
- Every time we go to a doughnut shop,
we ask the people at that doughnut shop
what their favorite
doughnut spot to eat at is
when you're not here.
- Donut Man in Glendora.
- This is exactly what I wanted to hear!
- Colin's already conked out.
He's in doughnut coma.
- Doughnut delirium.
- Hey, we're here!
- Huh?
(laughter)
- I've heard about this
place for a long time.
My dad grew up out here.
- Does he like it?
- I don't know.
- I feel like this place
is really, really on par
with making things look
really cool and crazy.
- Cheers! Cheers!
- [Jordan] It's nice and light.
- Dense and fluffy!
- Yeah! It's that weird
perfect combination
that you don't see in
doughnuts very often.
It's pretty cool.
- Chocolate frosted doughnut is more like
the auntie who consoles
you when you're down.
- Next up, we got this strawberry
insanity situation here.
- I feel like I'm eating
a bread bowl of soup,
but instead of soup, it's strawberries.
- Here!
- You know what I just realized?
- What?
- You can't have too many doughnuts.
- This isn't like tacos.
Tacos I could eat all day
and you just get full.
This, I feel like I might pop.
- I'm doughn-ed out!
(laughter)
- I dough-not want to
eat anymore doughnuts.
- We got to do it!
- Besides the doughnuts
here, where would you suggest
that we should go to next, for
our next doughnut adventure?
- All my coworkers are
saying Lady's Donuts.
- And Lady's Donuts is
right down the street.
- Let's go!
(clapping)
- Lady's Donuts unfortunately didn't
want to be on camera, so...
- We're asking the internet!
- Twitter said California Donuts.
- California Donuts, here we come!
(surf music)
- If I was a doughnut, I would be
something like apple cinnamon.
- I could see that.
- Little bit of sweet,
little bit of spicy.
- I'm a chocolate-covered
old fashioned doughnut.
- Why chocolate-covered?
- Because I like chocolate.
- Ohhh!
- I think I'd be maple bacon.
Many layers to the doughnut,
many layers to my life.
- I don't want to say a basic,
boring, old glazed doughnut,
but I think I would be a
basic, boring, glazed doughnut.
- [Freddie] Yes!
- [Colin] I absolutely agree with that.
- [Freddie] Absolutely.
- We've got to try the basic one.
- The one you connect most with.
- It's really good.
- It's a good donut.
- This is like the kind of bread
that you get at an Asian bakery.
- You can tell it's quality dough.
- Uh-huh.
- But more bready than I
would prefer for a doughnut.
- I would like to combine the
dough from California Donuts,
with the chocolate glaze at Donut Man.
- My pick is Donut Man in Glendora.
I think that was a special doughnut.
- This is my favorite doughnut.
Doughnut shop telephone works.
- I'm gonna have to say that Donut Friend
had my favorite chocolate glaze.
- I would say this doughnut wins
on sugar-to-dough ratio alone.
Let's get crazy!
- I'm gonna get this
green tea one right here.
- You don't like that?
- No!
- What's it taste like?
- It tastes like ewww.
- This is my favorite
doughnut of all time.
- Ughhh.
- That croissant?
- Now I have had a maple
bacon cronut before,
but not from here.
- [Jordan] Freddie, you look
like you're about to cry.
- It's so good.
- That's delicious!
- Yeah, it's good.
- That's really tasty.
- It's the bacon. I think it's because
I'm finally getting
some savory in my mouth.
(laughter)
- I have never pigged out on
anything else to this degree,
that made me feel as
awful as I do right now.
- Doughnuts are no joke.
I have been training
for this my whole life.
I still eat at least six
doughnuts every weekend.
- Yeah, doughnut delirium is
not an ideal state to be in,
but if you're with people that
you love, it's all worth it.
- Awww! You love me, Freddie?
- Eh.
- I love crazy, weird doughnuts!
- Yeah.
- You like the crazy doughnuts
like you like your crazy men?
(laughter)
- There you go!